norway is one of the world's biggest
producers of oil and gas but it's water
that provides almost all its domestic
power its steep valleys and abundant
rainfall are perfect for hydro
electricity
[Music]
huge reservoirs feed a network of pipes
and turbines built inside the mountains
producing so much green energy that some
will now be exported to britain through
a cable under the north sea the longest
in the world
when we talk about this project
people in their minds have you know
visualizing a cable or that size you
know but as you say it's not it's it's
about this it's um it's a technology
that's been proven and it works and we
can assure you that the 1.4 million
households will get their electricity
and it will be hydropower
the cable snakes along valleys in the
west of norway before diving beneath the
waves emerging in blythe northumberland
the hydroelectricity it brings should
reduce the uk's carbon emissions by 23
million tons by 2030.
one of the big challenges in the shift
to renewable energy is the intermittency
of supply sometimes the wind doesn't
blow and the sun doesn't shine but hydro
power could help fill the gap in effect
norway can be a giant battery for the uk
the uk now generates a quarter of its
electricity from wind but an unusually
calm summer at the same time that the
price of gas the usual standby spiked
left the national grid firing up a coal
power station to keep the lights on
as a result of the of this cable and all
of the other cables bills will fall and
that's because in the uk we can access
cheaper energy from the continent and
transport that energy through our
interconnectors
meaning that the people in the uk are
receiving energy from from cheaper more
plentiful sources of of green
electricity across across continental
europe
green energy could in time be exported
to norway as britain's wind capacity
almost doubles over the next decade but
for now much of the electricity will be
coming the other way once again it's
viking power that crosses the north sea
thomas more sky news in qildal norway